hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to huniepop we're here
talking to a cat I knew there was gonna
be a girl but probably not why would I
[Music]
was it mean when the cat is called feral
has no longer the best
[Music]
yeah oh can I can I talk to someone else
please anybody else please Lola please
[Music]
much better now much better Lola how are
you doing I'm gonna buy you a gift
you're so great Laura a compass every
girl likes a compass you really are
something else
yeah Marta what I can check actually I
forgot that I can check what I've
already talked her about wow I don't
know a lot last name age occupation cup
size hobby or fav color I thought I
asked you about your boobs already well
my full name is Lola REM bright slow
love them right what an interesting
really good question in my head
wait got it tell me what's the longest
relationship you've ever had a year and
nine months no what am I supposed to
answer to this not an appropriate answer
for you shut up
Campbell get you I'm gonna get you balls
girls like balls right how about this
boy yeah you've got to get something
inside me food I mean
I got this one
do you like cocoa nuts do you like some
cocoa nuts no she liked to ball are you
challenging me no oh you like sports
that's right I remember it's not just
about balls I remember things about
girls how much you weigh that's not rude
right would you consider yourself an
outdoorsy type yes absolutely
I can't stand to be cooped up inside
tell me what season I like most right I
[Applause]
am the sweetest with my little cheat
sheet all about you books do you like to
read ooh yeah I like fiction oh come on
this is really what I'm all about here
you've been paying attention when's my
birthday
[Music]
hey how about a date I was about to ask
you the same oh I didn't upgrade my who
nice but it's okay I didn't need to
spend all my hoodie's on that I'm doing
okay I come here all the time I don't
know maybe I'm not an idiot and I know
when there's a market in town me to do
this
[Music]
thank you yes thanks for joining me I'm
in a little bit of self celebration mode
here so just back off a little bit okay
[Music]
god damn it's time to go back to the
mega [ __ ] yeah yeah let's just go on
with our day cuz it's gonna be so much
fun when we're talking to the mega [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah I got Nooh you should come to my
yoga class someday don't worry you won't
be doing this I take it easy on
beginners oh that's nice I mean it's
just it's just what yoga is nothing
wrong about that this is from one of the
most intense masters I ever had I didn't
win but at least I was cute in the nerf
oh yeah that's right she likes tennis
that's adorable
thank you very much Oh dad to skip class
today I can't sit here and listen to
some [ __ ] talk about a bunch of [ __ ]
no one cares about three hours poink oh
wait already watch I already did that
all right okay so I'm gonna buy a
lighter coral what's your favorite color
average what's your favorite elects
mokan many doobies i like rolling some
joints and then having a good time
relaxing playing some b-ball outside of
the school
[Music]
well how rude - yeah okay I could pretty
cool okay I goes pretty cool Aiko's the
teacher I go see I like know what I'm
doing here I need a nap you're so close
once your relationship with the girls at
four or more hearts there's a good
chance you can pull her home after the
next date take her out at night though
that's the only way you're gonna pull it
off Oh what am I gonna be pulling off
[Music]
what do you like chopstick that cuz
she's Asian
cuz that really unique gift for a
Japanese woman oh boy racism oh I
thought hard on this one you wouldn't
believe how much I don't think no wait
gambling Oh classy classy oh my god I
deal with you but before I gotta up my
skills okay cool
got it you me you mean we're going date
a hot heavy date bad I know right more
nine just look at me I'm like the most
eligible bachelor in existence how about
I take you to the dog park with Momo
where the hell are we this is romantic
oh yes very much so
[Music]
nice Thanks I work on my combos all the
time
[Music]
about my personality which one of these
girls I'm actually gonna choose for the
ringing of the wholeness
let me try so I came home I'm gonna meet
my cat who I am the master of and she's
a person
[Music]
how old I said I was 28 who's next
I don't want to talk too much Momo's in
my bedroom
why is Momo in my bedroom does she
really live with me now because that
kind of creepy okay don't be a stranger
okay I'll try not to
I will try not to I can't remember from
eiko aha look I can almost fit this
whole thing in practice makes perfect
lol maybe next time that'll be you
[Music]
wonder that is mildly suggestive like
her well [ __ ] me I finally won something
at the casino great now maybe I can pay
put a tiny dent in my massive debt yeah
yeah okay all right cool okay Goku I
already bought you something
[Music]
I'll sleep super-good thanks for asking
I'll come back when I have more
inappropriate questions to make you
uncomfortable that's what I do need a
workout buddy you need someone help hold
up your boobs while you're working out
is that what we're talking about here
we're talking about some sombrero
exclusive gifts for a Latina oh that's
so racist that is the silliest stupidest
thing I've ever heard in my label Wow
how about some leg warmers and a tango
rose and a water bottle you got it I
know I know I know okay look it's me I
was about to board a plane for my
morning shift
I forget what city this is from
Washington maybe poink oh look at you
and your sassy little 1950s stewardess
outfit it's so damn cute not that cute I
guess they're pretty cute there maybe
keep me
thank you no actually not not at all
what do you do for like work oh I don't
know I do remember what is like uh what
is like I am my girl can I just can I
like oh I don't know anything about you
what am i doing to pay the bills I know
that actually you're a hairdresser
[Music]
okay got it
keep trying to I expecting like hitting
the ball okay so then I can upgrade just
a little more on one more thing my next
[Music]
okay all right so no I can do
Maxie's gonna alright so that's all the
time I have for huniepop now in the next
episode I might take a woman home back
to my place to meet my cat wouldn't that
be fun and then I don't know how much
more of this game I'm gonna play after
that but we'll see how it gets there so
thank you again everybody for watching
and as always I will see you
[Music]